quand on sera riche en crev quand on
sera riche en
crev et comment qu'on va se la payer et
comment qu'on va se la
payer la belle maison climatisée pleine
de placard et de
robinets
làhaut làhaut dans les beaux
quartiers quand on sera riche comme j'en
suis sûr quand on sera riche comme j'en
suis sûr
tu pourras faire nos petits tu pourras
faire nos
petits et ils seront tellement bien
élevés qu'on les prendra pour des
Anglais
làhaut làhaut dans les beau
quartier quand on comptera plus nos
millions faudra reprendre ton
violon tu travailleras pour t'amuser
comme tu dirais pour te relaxer
et comme tout le monde tu feras du bien
aux artistes et aux orphelins làhaut
tout làhaut dans les beaux
quartiers quand on sera riche comme
c'est écrit tu t'habilleras à
Paris tu feras ton marcher en vison
bonjour madame 4
saisons pas nouveau rich pour dessous
faudrait pas qu'on se moque de nous
là-haut là-haut dans les beaux
quartiers parole on aura du soleil du
vrai du Grand du plein
soleil jusque dans le garage à Rols
jusque dans le garage à
re et tu feras du skinotique dans ta
baignoire en céramique là-haut oh
là-haut dans les beaux quartiers
tiens je te promets dimanche prochain
ouais je te promets dimanche
prochain on ira se prendre le tram on
ira se prendre le
tram et tous les deux on choisira la
belle maison où l'on vivra un jour
làhaut dans les
[Musique]
beauti
làut
[Musique]
làut merci Gilbert merci